there's been some speculation about our
friendship with Russell Crowe kind of
blossoming and we were very lucky to
have known Russell for a number of years
so he was Steve's friend and then after
Steve died he became a loyal friend of
the Irwin family but we're just friends
but he's amazing so he's a really great
dad too we all love Russell and she's
not in love it's just nice to know
someone who's so loyal I think it was
steve maraboli who said i dread when it
comes to friends I'd rather have four
quarters than a hundred pennies and he's
definitely that kind of stand-up loyal
guy but that's not the only rumor the
Irwin family dispelled on Saturday at
the Steve Irwin gala in Beverly Hills
here's what bindi said about her
boyfriend
Chandler Powell well we haven't moved in
together that's for sure he's he still
splits his time between Florida and then
also Australia he comes to visit a lodge
and is actually really amazing when it
comes to wildlife I think that's because
he's such a kind and caring soul you
have to treat animals the way that you
would wish to be treated and I'm so
lucky Chandler Chandler is such a
blessing and always kind and wonderful
absolutely and it's been so much fun
because back in Australia Zoo I've been
throwing Chandler in with all of the
animals he's done such a great job
[Music]